[Müzik]
Herkese merhaba
tahmin ediyorum ama o Tahmin ettiğiniz
şey bende yok kanser değilim bir başka
Hikayem Var ama önce biraz kendimden
bahsetmek istiyorum size biraz başa
alalım konuyu ben nasıl bir çocuktum
nasıl bir hayat yaşadım sonra konuma
gireceğim ben Aslı Ankaralıyım Annem
emekli öğretmen Babam emekli bir
bürokrat bir ablam var bir de çok yeni
kocam var
Ben küçükken çok tuttuğunu koparan bir
Kızdım yani böyle her istediğimi Yaptım
hatta biraz örnek vereyim Ben daha 4-5
yaşlarında okuma yazmam yok asla hiçbir
şekilde bir şey bilmiyorum ablam
Hacettepe Üniversitesi Devlet
Konservatuvarı da yarı zaman şans
bölümünde okuyordu o her derse
girdiğinde ben arkasından ağlıyordum Ben
de gireceğim beni de alsınlar bu derse
diye sonra da ablamın öğretmenleri daha
fazla benim bu acıma dayanamadılar ve
benim sadece şarkı söylenecek Yani artık
o notu okunmayacak bölüme girmeme izin
verdiler hatta biraz daha ileri gittiler
Benim final konserine de çıkmaması
sağladılar
çok mutluyum şarkı söylüyorum düşünün
Cumhurbaşkanlığı Senfoni Orkestrası
dönem konseri herkes konservatuarlı
ortada bir bit var O da benim azmimin
zaferi diyebiliriz zaten odaklanın sonra
çok da sahneden doğru düzgün bir kimse
indiremedi bunun hemen arkasından TRT
Ankara Radyosu çok sesli sözcük korusuna
gittim orada zaten 5 yıl sürüyor Orası
ses telleriniz yavaştan böyle ergenliğe
girdiğinizde kısılmasın diye sizi erken
yaşta emekli ediyorlar Böylece ilk
emekliliğimi almış oldum oradan
ayrılırken öğretmenlerim demiş ki anneme
babama çok hareketli onu gidin buz
patenine mi yazdırıyorsunuz dansa mı
yazdırıyorsunuz bir enerjisini atsın
demişler Annemlerde Sağ olsunlar Hiç
kırmamışlar benim öğretmenlerime onların
sözünü dinlemişler ve Benim 16 yıllık
dans macera başlattılar
güzel bir dansı hayatım oldu dünyayı
gezdim Ben 7 kıtada gerçekten 7 kıtada
temsil yaptım Barış Manço'nun Kara
Sevda'ya söylediği Salonu hatırlarsınız
herkesin bayrak salladı ben o salonda
Japon prensine karşı dans ettim Eyfel
Kulesi'nde Eyfel kulesinin altında bütün
bir neredeyse Fransa'ya dans ettim 7
kıtayı gezdim 16 yıllık dans maceramda
inanılmaz Anılar biriktirdim
son üniversitenin son dönemine doğru bir
başka hayalim olan bir şey daha oldu ve
benim beni Anadolu ateşine Davet ettiler
Böylece İstanbul macera mı başlamış oldu
Anadolu ateşinden sonra artık yönüme
başka bir yere döndürmeye karar verdim
Bu sefer başka bir hedefim vardı o da
kurumsal bir firmaya girip kurumsal
iletişim departmanına girmekte Babamın
bir lafı vardır bu hayatta neyi yapmak
istiyorsan yap ama yapabileceğinin en
iyisini yap diye Ben de bunu düstur
edindim ve işi mutfağında öğreneyim diye
daha önce üniversitedeyken yarı
zamanında çalıştığım bir ajansa tam
zamanında işe girdim Çünkü işi mutfağını
öğrenip orada kurumsal hayatı adım atmak
istiyordum Ajans tarafı biraz yoğun
geçer böyle streslidir geceniz Gündüz
olmaz
Hatta hafta sonları hiçbir şekilde bir
şeyiniz olmaz yani biraz streslidir
bunları niye anlatıyorum ben size şimdi
diyeceksiniz ki bu kız bize bunları neyi
anlatıyor Çünkü o çok istediğim kurumsal
firmanın iş görüşmesine gireceğim
dönemde Bir Sabah uyandım
saçlarımı topladım
Saçlarımdan bir bölümü yoktu
önce anlamadım
aynaya gittim bakmaya çalıştım
göremedim de Çünkü arka tarafta koca bir
bölüm yoktu ajansa gittim ajanstaki
arkadaşlarıma gösterdim böyle Derin Bir
Sessizlik Aynı bu salon gibi dedim ki
bir sıkıntı var
ama o kadar stresli bir dönemden
geçiyorduk ki işler çok yoğundu ben
kesin strese olduğunu düşünüyorum zaten
herkeste böyle Ay çok stresliydi falan
diyor Yalnız ben daha sonra birazcık
daha Saçlarıma kaybettim Sonra kaşlarım
Kirpiklerim
derken bütün vücudum gitti hastalığımın
adı alopesi alopesi üniversite Bu bir
bağışıklık sistemi hastalığı Benim
bağışıklık sistemim Saçlarıma virüs
zannediyor ve döküyor
o Tabi bu bağışıklık sistemim oyunu
benim hayatıma dönülmez ve noktaya soktu
O çok istediğim iş görüşmesine girerken
kafa dilimde böyle garip garip boşluklar
vardı ve ben onları kimse görmesin Kimse
benim saçsız olduğumu yani norm bir şey
olduğunu görmesinler diye karbonla
boyayarak girdim iş görüşmesine
doktorların bana o kortizon tedavisinde
artık hastaneye yatmam gerektiğini
söylediği dönemde işe alındım çok güzel
bir haber gibi gözüküyor çünkü o
istediğin bir şey yapacağım ama benim
için çok korkunç bir haber verdi Çünkü
kel Bir kadın niye işe alsınlar diye
düşünüyordum
işe alındım kesin kovulacağım diyorum
gittim kendime bir önceki işimden kalan
maaşımın bir bölümüyle bir peruk aldım
gerçek saçtan
her sabah kalkıyorum İşe gitmeden önce
böyle üniformamı giyinir gibi peruğunu
takıyorum sonra Akşam işten çıkınca
Levent metrosunda atm'lerin orada ücra
köşeler olur Ben o icraat köşelerinin
hepsini biliyordum Çünkü Superman gibi
Kafamdaki peruğunu çıkarıp öyle eve
devam ediyordu o dönem beni erkek
arkadaşım Tabii ki hemen terk ettim
hani kalabalıklarda böyle etrafa
girersiniz çok tanıdıktır o Sima ama bir
türlü ismini bilemezsiniz İşte o benim
ünlü kişi benim herkes ünlülerle
fotoğraf çektirmek ister ünlüler Ben de
çekinmek istiyor gerçekten buna
inanamazsınız kimler benimle fotoğraf
çekildi ve bence şu anki en iyisi en iyi
bölüm
Herkes bana metroda yer veriyor
bu toplumda kadın olmak zor Çünkü Kadın
dediğin bakımlı olacak Kadın dediğin
sırma saçlı olacak Kadın dediğin
psikolojisi bozulduğunda gidip kuaförde
saçını kestirecek
bakım ürünlerinin birçoğu benim kapsama
alanının dışında ağdalar Lazer seansları
epilasyon ürünleri bunların hiçbiri
bende yok yani toplama bir şekilde
kadından beklediği şeyleri ben topluma
veremiyorum beni dışlayacak mısınız peki
ben de işte benim dışlayacağınızı
düşünüyorum o psikolojiyle bir yandan
İşime böyle sıkı sıkı tutunuyorum bir
yandan da her gece evde kendimle
yüzleşiyorum
Benim evim nelere şahit oldu bilseniz
Ben Aynalar parçaladım ben bu hale nasıl
geldim krizleri yaşadım gece Eski
sevgilimi Arar gibi ablamı arayıp En
yakın arkadaşım İkisi de buradalar
onları arayıp ben vazgeçtim bu hayattan
dediğim konuşmalar yaptım
çok fazla doktora gittim çok fazla
tedavi yöntemi denedim Hatta tedavi
olmayan yöntemlerde denedim bunun
Okumakla alakası yok arkadaşlar
Çaresizlik böyle bir şey Hatta bir
tanesini size söyleyeyim
kafanızın derisine böyle tuz ruhu gibi
bir solüsyon sürüyorsunuz ve bulaşık
süngerinin o yeşil bölümüyle kafanızı
zımparalıyorsunuz Ben bunu yaptım hem de
haftada 3 kere yaptım neden güzel olayım
diye ya Yani o dışarıda gidip de Kel
olduğu için
utanan yürüyemeyen ben o seanslar
sonrası soyulmuş domates gibi gezmeye
utanmıyordum
bu seansların olduğu dönemde böyle
yanımda 6-7 yaşlarında bir kız çocuğu
var o da benimle aynı salonda aynı
işkenceye maruz kalıyor
göz göze geldik
Ben o gün daha fazla dayanamayacağımı
anlamıştım tek bir çarem kalmıştı kabul
etmek kabul edince her şey değişti çünkü
nasıl geri dönebilirsin diye
düşünüyorsun aynaları Parçalıyorsun eski
fotoğraflarına bakıyorsun ablanı en
yakın arkadaşını arıyorsun geri
dönemiyorsun O zaman kabul edeceksin ama
burada önemli bir ayrıntı var
kabul boyun eğmek değil kabul olanı
olduğu gibi görmek eylemi yani
kararlarını yargılarını her şeyi bir
kenara bırakıp gerçekle yüzleşebilmektir
kabul zaten böyle baktığınızda boyun
eğmek olmuyor bu farklı bir eylem oluyor
bir devrim oluyor demişti bir arkadaşım
ben de ilk eylemimi bir etkinliğimizde
aldım Sonra bırakma konserinde
sponsorluk ve
arkasında sıra bırakmanın arkasında
çalacak müzisyen arkadaşların var benim
de onlara tabi hepsini tanıyorum ama o
güne kadar sosyal medyada tek bir pozun
bile yok çünkü kendimden çok utandığım
için hiçbir şekilde kendimi
paylaşmıyordum
Onların da beni böyle görmesini çok
istemiyordum
ömrüm boyunca dik durdum ben
o peruğun altındaki güçsüz hastayı
kimseye göstermek istemedim
ve o gün dedim ki ben kendimle
yüzleşeceğim Herkesle yüzleşeceğim bu
akşam çok korkuyordum ama insanlar
içeriye girdiklerinde Ben kafada
peruksuz bekliyordum çok korkmuştum beni
korkacaklarını düşünüyordum Tabii ki
olmadılar hatta o kadar güzel bana
destek oldular o kadar çok sarıldılar ki
Ben dalga dalga büyüdüm o kadar
özgüvenim yerime geldi ki size anlatamam
sosyal medyada hemen fotoğraflarını
paylaşmaya başlamıştım
ilk postumun ardından bir anneden mesaj
aldım
bu annenin 8 yaşında bir oğlu varmış
benimle aynı hastalığa sahip ve ona her
akşam hikaye okuduktan sonra benim
fotoğraflarımı gösteriyormuş
Hatta bu güzel çocuk Akşamları bazen
hikaye yerine direkt o kel ablayı göster
bana diyormuş
Bu biraz bana annemle babamı hatırlattı
Annemle babam Bütün bunlar benim başıma
geldiğinde bana bir kere bile olsun
demediler olsun böyle de güzelsin asla
demediler onlar hep çok güzel oldun her
şey daha güzel olacak Ve hep senin
yanındayız dediler teşekkür ediyorum
kendilerine
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
o anneden sonra ben dedim ki bunu
paylaşacağım Çünkü biliyordum ki benim
gibi olan ve bu toplumda kendini bir
şekilde saklayan gizleyen bir sürü insan
vardı ve onlar da aslında kabul ederse
bir şekilde dışarıya rahatlıkla
çıkabileceklerdi uzun yıllar Affet
tiyatro ödüllerini yürütücülüğünü yaptım
bu ödüller sayesinde tanıştığım bir
arkadaşımla ilk röportajımı verdim Bunun
arkasından daha da ilginç mesajlar
gelmeye başladı bana Mesela
Erzurum'da saçlarını koparma hastalığına
yakalanmış Birisi bana mesaj attı Ona
doktorlarının arkadaşlarının
Hatta ailesini bile vermediği
motivasyonu vermişim benim bütün bu
röportajımın fotoğraflarını kesip
duvarına asmış bana Onların
fotoğraflarını yolladı yıllardır
peruğunu çıkarmayan insanlar peruklarını
çıkarmışlar ve herkes bir şekilde
benimle tanışabilmek için gün saydığını
söyledim
Tabii ki bir kadın olarak
kafamı kurcalayan bir sürü soru daha
vardı Mesela biri bana bir daha aşık
olabilecek miydi
bir gün Gerçekten bir çocuğum olursa
benim yüzümden kendini eksik
hissedebilecek miydi
Bunlar benim yeğenlerim Ali ve ata Ben
küçükken annemin saçlarıyla oynayarak
uyurdum Ali'nin Mercan da aynı benim
gibi annesini saçlarıyla oynayarak
uyuyor Ali'nin yalnızca benimle hiç saça
ihtiyaç duymuyor buraya koyuyor kafasına
Biz birlikte rahat rahat uyuyabiliyoruz
Bir de onlar küçükken
sokakta gördükleri her kel adama teyze
diyorlardı
pandemi hepimizin hayatında çok bir şey
değiştirdi özellikle benim gibi
Yalnızlar kulübünde alternatif böyle
yerler keşfetmeye sağladım
artık en son Yalnızlıktan evde
çaydanlığımla konuşmaya başladığım zaman
dedim ki ben evde daha fazla
kalamayacağım benim bir şeyler yapmam
lazım bir yerlere gitmem lazım uzun
zamandır da yerken sporuyla uğraşıyorum
dedim ki ben teknede yaşayayım
sonra tabii ki öyle beyaz yakalaysan
rahat rahat gidip teknede yaşayamıyorsun
Ben de yönümü İstanbul marinalarında
sahiplerinin teknelerini çok da
gitmediği teknelere çevirdim onlara
dedim ki Marina kirası böyle 12 bunun
kirasını vereceğim ve aynı sizin kadar
iyi bakacağımın teminatını veriyorum
Tabii ki Türkiye'de böyle bir şey
olmadığı için herkes Öncelikle normal
olarak deli dedi bana ama 7 gününde bu
arada size anlatamam yani ben Yelkenci
camiasını tanıdık tanımadık 7 cihana
haber saldım bunu 7 gün bana haber geldi
güzel haber birisi bana teknesini
vermeyi kabul etti çok güzel Ben artık
Marina hayatıma başlamış oldum
Tabii pandemi koşulları Bir yandan
kapamalar var Dolayısıyla Marina'da
yalnızca ben tekneler ve Martılar var
bir noktadan sonra benim çaydanlığımın
yerine vinç kolu almaya başladı ve ben
onu trip atmaya başladım fark ettim Tam
öyle bir anda
birkaç yan teknede sesler duydum bir
cuma akşamı insan Koşarak gittim
yanlarına ben de sizinle bu akşam
eğlenebilir miyim dedim Sağ olsunlar
hemen beni davet ettiler çok tatlılar o
akşam o kadar soğuktu ki hava onların
dışarıda oturduğunu da gördüm bir
şekilde yani teknedeki Yatağım daha
güzel geldi bana sıcak sıcak ben
gidemedim yanlarına ve uyudum gözüme ve
açtım gece o Sen Kahkahalar devam ediyor
Ben de öyle bir ruh halindeyim ki bir
yandan diyorum ki
Ben de gitseydim biz de eğlenebilirdik
bir adamım
biraz daha Saygı olsun diyorum tam böyle
gelgitli ruh halimdeyim Sabah kalktım
Tekneyi yıkıyorum o Sen kahkahanın
sahibi beni kahve içmeye davet etti
kendisiyle o günden bugüne son iki aydır
da aynı soyadla
kahve içmeye devam ediyoruz
eşim Cihangir reklam filmi yönetmeni
onun Engin Yönetmenlik tecrübelerinden
yararlanarak Biz Marina hayatımızı hafif
tilya alan videolar çekmeye başlamıştık
ta ki nisan 2022'de Oscar töreninde Will
Smith o christia Tokatı atana kadar
kristruck'ın Aslında o esprisi belki
herkese komik gelmiş olabilir ama
oradaki sıkıntı şuydu
usbit'in karısı benimle aynı hastalığa
sahip ve o kabullenme sürecini henüz
geçmemişler ama benim için daha kötü
olan ve beni üzen tarafı şuydu bir insan
sevdiği için böyle bir şiddete yani
birilerini maruz bırakır mıydı ona çok
emin değilim ve ben hakikaten beynimden
vurulmuşa döndüm o anı görünce Üstelik
Hani ben hep iyi tarafından anlatmaya
çalışıyorum bu hastalığın birileri
dünyaya o kadar kötü bir şekilde tanıttı
ki bu hastalığı böyle kahroldum ve o gün
birçok arkadaşımdan mesaj aldım Telefon
açtı bana dediler ki bir şey yapmayacak
mıyız benim gibi aynı hastalığa sahip
olan kızı olan bir arkadaşıma el şaka
takan Onunla beraber sürekli telefonda
konuşuyoruz Ne yapalım Ne yapalım Ben
dedim ki ben ben bir post atacağım
Cihangir'i yazacağım üstüne Altına da
diyeceğim ki aslında Sevgi böyle bir şey
değildir Cihangir dedi ki gel Bu
duygularını bir videoya çekelim ve sen
gerçekten ne hissettiğini anlat Çok iyi
fikir akşam Ela Cihangir sevgili Selim
kemahlı ve Ayşe bale Biz hep beraber
yani reklam dünyasına Şampiyonlar Ligi
Ve ben hep beraber bir masada oturduk ve
ben onlara böyle kelliğin ne kadar kolay
olduğunu anlatmaya çalıştım böyle bir
konuşma yapıyorum dediler ki hemen bir
film çekelim ertesi gün set ertesi gün
montaj 3 gün film yayında filmimizin adı
olduğun gibisin bu toplumda kendini
öteki hisseden herkesin filmi olsun
istedik ve bu bir farkındalık hareketi
olsun istedik Tabii ben bir sosyal
medyada bulunup paylaşınca annem babam
dayım amcam falan derken bir anda Yekta
Kopan ecevitler Ezgim ola Gülse Birsel
derken Ayşe Arman Biz 41.6 milyon izleme
ile Türkiye'nin yarısına ulaşmış
reklam camiasının
oscarları sayılan kristal elma ve
filiste de ödüle layık görülerek büyük
bütçeli reklam dünyasında
sivil bir inisiyatifin 0 bütçe ve sadece
sevgiyle yapılmış bir filmin de ödül
aldığına layık gördük ve bu yüzden de
herkese çok müteşekkiriz sağ olsunlar
bizi değerlendirdikleri için
[Alkış]
son öbürünü de görün de ondan sonra
kapatayım
kapatırken Ben bu hayatta Ne istediysem
oldu
bu TED konuşmasını yapmak da benim en
büyük hayallerimden biriydi şimdi
huzurlarınızda bu hayalime bir tek öteye
taşımak istiyorum çünkü konuşmanın
başında da söylediğim gibi tuttuğunu
koparan Aslı Belki bunu filmi falan
çekilir burada hepinize Kanıt olsun
ya ayrı canım
bir farklılığı hastalığı olsun olmasın
bu toplumda kendini öteki hisseden
herkesin nasıl söylemek istediğin bir
şey var
Hiçbirimiz birbirimizden farklı değiliz
bugün benim başıma gelen Yarın sizin de
başınıza gelebilir eğer farklı göründüğü
için birisine acıyarak baktığınızda
yakalarsanız kendinizi lütfen kendinize
bir sorun
Neticede Bu bir insan hikayesi Belki o
kadar uzak bir hikaye de değil Belki
sandığınız kadar felaket haberi de değil
farklı gördüğünüz herkesin hatırı var
üzerimizde Çok teşekkür ediyorum beni
dinlediğiniz için